Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved
incredible success
as entrepreneurs and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
I know what you're thinking,
but no, we're not models.
Awful.
We're creative guys.
You're telling me I'm walking
around with this problem
that I never realized
that I had.
Sales are just north
of $4 million.
‐What?
‐Wow.
Narrator:
This the art of doing business.
Are you done, Mr. O'Leary?
I'm not finished yet.
This is "Shark Tank."
Do you think I'm gonna pay you
at the Mavs' arena?
‐Yes.
‐No.
I'll make you an offer.
Cuban:
I'll consider helping Kevin.
Why would anybody
help Kevin?
I got to wet my beak.
Can we hear what Kevin
has to say first?
‐Nope.
‐Ouch.
‐I'm Eric Huang.
‐And I'm Steven Mazur.
And we live
in Detroit, Michigan.
Eric and I met
through Venture for America.
Which is a nonprofit
that connects college grads
with start‐ups
in America's emerging cities.
We put our heads together,
and we realized we both have
the same problem,
and so did millions of other
guys around the country,
and that's when we started
Ash & Anvil.
Service.
I was born and raised
in Detroit,
and I graduated high school
in 2009.
That year, the recession
in Detroit was at its peak,
and the auto industry
was at its worst.
Detroit was in a tough spot,
but that's why I wanted to build
a company here.
There we go!
All right.
I moved here three years ago,
and in those three years,
there's been
incredible change ‐‐
new restaurants,
new construction everywhere.
Really big opportunity
for us to be a part of it.
I think a lot of guys
would like that.
It's hard to start a business
whatever generation you are,
but for millennials,
it's even tougher.
We don't have as much experience
or resources
to really get
off the ground.
I think what we do have
is an ambition to get it done.
Detroit's the comeback city,
and it's the underdog,
and as a smaller company,
we feel like that, too.
There's a lot that the country
could learn from Detroit,
and we think that it's a great
place to build a business.
♪♪
[ Chuckles ]
Hi, Sharks!
I'm Eric Huang.
And I'm Steven Mazur.
And we're
from Detroit, Michigan.
‐Our company ‐‐
‐Hey, hey!
I don't think
they can see us.
Guys, can you go
stand over there?
[ Chuckles ]
That's much better.
Our company is Ash & Anvil,
and we're seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 12.5% of our company.
As you can see,
we're short.
Us shorter guys
have a really tough time
finding shirts that fit.
We're forced to either
buy custom clothes,
tailor everything we purchase,
or do something that really
boosts the old self‐esteem ‐‐
shop in the kids section
just to get the right fit.
Look at the shirts
we're wearing today!
These shirts
do not look good.
The sleeves and body lengths
are too long,
the neck is too big, and
the overall fit doesn't work.
‐Awful.
‐These are ‐‐
These are normal clothes
made for guys like them,
not for guys like us.
These are the only available
options for shorter guys.
Now, let's try
Ash & Anvil.
‐Whoo!
‐[ Chuckles ]
Wow!
All right.
Now, I know
what you're thinking,
but no,
we're not models.
But our everyday shirt will
sure make you feel like one.
It fits much, much better.
The lengths are correct
and the shirt fits
a shorter guy like me.
Sharks, with your investment,
we can continue to grow
our sales to heights
we can only dream of
and achieve our goal
of keeping grown men everywhere
from shopping
in the kids section.
Thanks, guys.
We're all set.
Watch your head
on the way out.
We brought some shirts today
if you'd like to take a look.
All right.
Thank you, Eric.
Yep.
Here you go, Lori.
‐Thank you.
And Kevin.
‐Ash & Anvil.
‐Appreciate that.
‐Thank you.
‐"Shorter guy clothes."
You got it.
Guys, it is wise to brand it
"shorter guys' clothes"
given the stigma
you just spoke about?
‐You tell us, Kevin.
‐Excuse me.
[ Laughs ]
I'm of medium height.
We thought a ton about,
how do we brand this?
Do we say
"vertically challenged"?
Do we say "not so tall"?
What's the best way
to do it?
And we ended up
with "shorter guy clothes"
'cause we were sick of trying
to beat around the bush.
Why is it called Ash & Anvil?
So, Ash comes
from Detroit City's motto ‐‐
"We will arise
from the ashes."
And Anvil's a tribute to the
manufacturing legacy of Detroit.
That's cool.
Oh, very cool.
‐Thanks.
‐Steven, I'm a tall guy.
‐What's a short guy considered?
‐What's a shorter guy's height?
‐Yeah.
‐So, when we did our studies
and did a ton of fittings
to get our style down,
guys that were
5'8" and below
fit better in our clothes
than traditional ones.
What? Are you saying
I'm short because I'm ‐‐
‐5'8"?
‐How tall are you?
‐I'm 5'6", myself.
‐5'8", myself.
Yeah, our average
customer's 5'5".
Let me see.
I'm 5'8".
You're 5'8"?
You're not 5'8"
Yeah, look at the heels.
Look at the heels.
‐I'm5'8".
‐I'm 5'6".
5'6".
‐Oh, no, Daymond.
‐Wow.
Get off your toes, Daymond.
Get off your toes.
You're a little taller
than he is.
You are not 5'8",
my friend,
‐I'm 5'8".
‐You are not ‐‐
I told people I was 5'7"
for years. I'm 5'8".
I'm 5'8".
‐You're 5'8"?
‐Yeah.
Daymond, you've shrunk.
I'm 5'8".
Not anymore,
you're not.
What do you got in sales?
So, since launching
nine months ago,
we have over $130,000
of sales so far.
‐After nine months?
‐After nine months.
Okay.
That's not horrible.
That's on our website, 100%,
and we've sold out twice.
It's all online.
Everything's online, right?
‐That's correct, yep.
‐100%.
Tell us what you sell
those shirts for,
what are your margins,
all the business stuff.
Yep. Our shirts retail
for $79,
and our margin right now
is about 55%.
When we first designed
our fit,
we went to the streets and found
hundreds of shorter guys
and said, "Hey, come over
to our apartment, have a beer,
try on prototypes ‐‐
That'll go over real well
in Detroit.
‐Whoa! Whoa, whoa!
‐Hey, it worked!
It worked!
They came over,
they tried on prototypes.
Looked at every
little detail ‐‐
things like the collar
and the tail drop, the cuffs.
It's always smart
to go ask people
what are their thoughts
to get feedback.
That's why social media
is so great today.
So, what do you guys
really need?
Our biggest challenge right now
is inventory.
How do you acquire the database
of 5'5" guys?
[ Laughs ]
Like, how do you find
that customer?
It's an interesting
challenge.
It's a subset of a subset‐subset
market because it's ‐‐
'Cause I'm way
out of your target market.
Well, how big is the market,
is what he's trying to say.
So, if you look at it,
there' one in three American men
are 5'8" and under,
which represents
over 40 million adults
in the U. S. alone.
That's why I always felt
that I was a little shorter
than the average‐sized person
because Kevin's
around my height,
Robert's around my height...
I'm way taller.
‐Yeah.
‐You understand what I'm saying?
You're telling me
I'm walking around
with this problem that
I never realized that I had.
And I think
this is for a man
who wears his shirt
outside of his pants,
so then, of course,
it looks baggy.
I always wear my shirt
inside my pants.
So I think
you're too well‐dressed
for most of America,
really.
If you look
at clothes now,
you could buy a suit
in short, right?
I know I wear
a 40 short suit.
Everything else
is small, medium, large,
and it's made
for a 6‐foot guy.
We're selling clothes that
are more everyday and casual ‐‐
Steven, I think
it's a very clever idea.
I think you guys
are doing a good job.
Thank you.
Not really my line of clothing.
It doesn't fit me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
We have clothes
that guys love.
We have 900 happy customers
that want to buy more shirts.
So it's about financing
enough to meet that demand
and preparing
for new products.
And we haven't
even talked
about things like
jeans, chinos, shorts...
Master what you're doing first,
right?
‐Exactly.
‐And you guys are really smart.
You're doing
everything right.
But for me, I don't think
I'm the right partner for you,
so for that reason,
I'm going out.
Thank you.
We've looked at brands
like Destination XL
and Lane Bryant,
who really led the way
for plus‐size women
and big‐and‐tall men.
You have plus‐size women
and petite women.
You have big‐and‐tall men,
and then there's nothing,
even though a third of us
are short.
I'm puzzled
on how to market it accurately.
And, you know, I think it's
an emotional thing, as well.
I don't want to accept
the fact
that I need
special clothes, probably.
But you still need them.
This is not for me.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Kevin and Mark?
What are you doing, Mark?
We're sold out,
and guys continually come to us
wanting to buy shirts.
And again, the biggest challenge
is inventory.
Once we get more inventory in,
we know we can do it.
Cuban: You know, guys,
I like it, right?
I like your focus on it.
I think there's a niche
opportunity there.
I'll make you an offer
12.5% is not enough.
I'm gonna have to get 25%,
but I'll offer you $150,000.
‐For 25%?
‐Right, for the 25%.
So that's my offer.
It's not a negotiation.
It's not a "Let me see
what Kevin has to say."
It's a yes‐or‐no conversation.
We really appreciate the offer,
would love to work with you.
We've spent a lot of time
getting to this point.
Can we hear what Kevin
has to say first?
Nope.
Wise man.
Herjavec: Wow.
Your call, guys.
Bird in the hand.
$150,000. 25%.
I'll do the $100K for 15%.
What do you think?
I'm out, guys.
We'll ‐‐
If you're in,
we'll take the offer.
Okay.
You're lucky I like you.
O'Leary:
Wow, you're lucky he likes you.
Nice moonwalk.
A tall guy working
with the short men!
I love it.
Excited about that,
about making money.
‐Appreciate it.
‐My pleasure, guys.
Next time,
when you get a yes, take it.
‐Okay.
‐We will. Thank you.
You almost lost that deal.
That was a serious moonwalk,
boys.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you!
Cuban: Thanks, guys.
‐Whew!
‐Wow.
We could become the first
big company for shorter guys,
and there's a lot of us
out there
that are looking
for clothes.
We do have a chip on our
shoulder, and we're underdogs.
Detroit's the underdog city,
shorter guys are underdogs,
and we're an underdog company.
But we're gonna
make it work.
‐Whew!
‐[ Sighs ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a premium version
of a special event activity.
♪♪
Man, I like that hat.
Hello, Sharks,
I'm Sean Spencer.
And I'm Ryan Glenn,
and we are Mirmir
from Los Angeles, California.
We're here today seeking
$350,000 for 10% equity stake
in our company.
Mirmir is reinventing
how and where photos
are captured on a global scale.
The good old‐fashioned
photo booth.
It's the world's
first selfie machine
and taker
of horrible photos.
Their end results are always
cheap and tacky and childish,
and that's why
they're never framed
and they're never
shared online.
So meet the future.
Mirmir, the photo booth that
makes everybody look beautiful.
Our proprietary software
instantly smoothes your skin,
adding this radiant glow.
You can always take
a good photo with Mirmir,
no matter who are you.
I mean, if we could make
this guy look good...
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
Greiner:
Look at your glowing skin, Mark.
It's our cutting‐edge technology
that has Mirmir being invited
to the most
exclusive parties
and high‐end events
in the world.
So we would like
to invite you all
to come out now
so we can take some photos
and make everybody
look beautiful with Mirmir.
Yeah!
‐Let's do it.
‐Come on, Lori!
‐Coming.
‐Everybody, come on.
Everybody?
All right.
Let's get a couple
with everybody in it.
All right,
let's get everybody in here!
Everybody in like
you love each other.
‐Can you fit us all in?
‐1, 2, 3.
I love that.
‐Daymond, Lori?
‐Oh, wow!
‐Oh, my God!
‐That's incredible!
‐That actually is beautiful.
Awesome.
Herjavec: First of all,
let me tell you this.
You guys were at my wedding.
‐We were.
I didn't get a chance to use it,
but my wedding planner Mikey
booked you guys in,
and I saw the photos after,
and I was like, "Wow!
The photos are amazing!"
Why are the photos so good?
Um, well,
it's a number of things.
So photo booths
have been around forever.
They've always been cheap
and tacky and childish
and gimmicky
and low quality,
and we're both
photographers,
and we wanted to take
studio‐quality photographs
in sort of a photo‐booth‐like
experience,
something that's instant
and something that's quick.
But tell me
what's unique about it.
So, through flattering
lighting ‐‐ That's huge.
Lighting, as you guys know,
is big.
Mm‐hmm.
Software.
We have software
that instantly goes in
and gives you a very tasteful
amount of retouching.
What does the software do?
How does it work?
So, my background is also
in fashion
in terms of photography,
and so I'm used to sitting
for two, three days at a time,
you know, retouching.
So what we decided was
why can't you retouch
in four seconds?
There's got to be
a way to do it, right?
There's an app called Smoothing
that does that quite nicely.
Cuban: There's a lot of apps
that do this.
Yeah, there's nothing ‐‐
Yeah, but it's really
beautiful.
You guys
pre‐select a filter
that you think
is most appropriate,
but there's no
secret sauce there.
Like we've said,
you've been at a couple events.
You guys at the hot brand,
the hot photo booth right now.
So tell us
what that's translated into,
and how are you
gonna stay hot?
Um, well, I think,
in terms of dollars,
if you want to talk
about that ‐‐
‐Yeah, that's why we're here.
‐Sure.
Sales in three years
are just north of $4 million.
Wow. And how many machines
do you have?
Right now,
we have nine machines.
And tell us
about the business model.
So, baseline price
in larger markets,
in New York or Los Angeles,
is $2,750.
That would get you
just the photo booth itself
and the printing.
We also have the texting,
and social media aspect of it.
Those are add‐ons.
‐What's the highest package?
‐$3,650.
Is it mainly weddings,
bar mitzvahs, festive type of...
So, our core business model
has been live events.
We've busted our butts
for three years now 24/7.
‐It's just been the two of us.
‐All on the West Coast, right?
‐All over the country.
‐No, right now ‐‐
We work all over
the U. S.
You package this up,
you ship it?
We take it on a plane
with us, yeah.
Herjavec: Sean, you did
$1.4 million with 9.
How do you do more?
If you had more machines,
would you sell more?
Absolutely. I mean,
that's also why we're here.
We need more machines,
we need marketing,
we need sales.
On a Thursday, Friday, Saturday,
we are at capacity.
We can't meet demand right now.
So Monday Tuesday, Wednesday,
they're not being used.
We can't meet
the demand you have.
‐No, we cannot meet demand.
‐We're telling people no.
‐What does a machine cost?
‐The machine would cost $22,000.
Ouch.
And how much money did you raise
to start this?
We didn't.
It's all personal.
‐It's all your own money?
‐Yeah, I mean ‐‐
‐How much did you put up?
‐Uh... [ Chuckles ]
It's kind of funny ‐‐
I mean, we think $250,000.
We think it's a little more
than that.
We stopped counting
at $250,000.
You came up
with the right lighting
so people have
a good experience.
Sure.
That's a win, right?
That's what matters
at the end of the day.
‐But as a potential investor...
‐Sure.
...I'm not getting a sense
that there were any unique
filters that were in there.
‐Right?
‐It's one filter.
Right, well,
that's what I'm saying, right?
We're producing
500 events a year.
We're taking care
of our families.
We're putting food
on the table.
And good for you.
What is the thing that you have
that's so valuable?
This.
‐What?
‐Demand.
‐High quality and ‐‐
‐High quality and demand.
We can't meet demand.
We're in four markets.
Yeah, but this is something
other people can replicate.
If somebody can replicate it
that easy,
why haven't they done it
in the last five years?
Okay, you've developed
one filter.
That's all your IP,
or what else?
O'Leary:
There is competition,
but what I'm trying
to figure out
is just the return
on investment.
Right now,
we're making $400,000 pre‐tax.
You get my $350,000.
What does the next
12 months look like?
Well, one, we would scale
just live events.
That's simple.
We would double
that quickly.
Venues is where we want to go,
and this is where ‐‐
Different business.
It is a different business,
and again,
that's why we're here.
We clearly have a skill set,
an expertise...
Do you think I'm gonna pay you
at the Mavs' arena
‐to come in and do this?
‐Yes.
No.
Why would they pay you?
We feel differently
because we are in conversations
with some of the biggest
retailers in the world.
Look, congratulations.
I'm not trying
to take away anything
from what
you've accomplished.
Sure.
It's more about what I see
in terms of an investment.
Right?
It's expensive and complicated,
and lot of people
are gonna use that as an entree
into this business.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Okay.
Sorry to hear that, Mark.
I really love this product,
and Mark is talking about it
from more
technical geek side, right?
I'm talking about it
from a consumer side.
So I love this product,
but I notice myself ‐‐
Every other day,
I buy a new gadget
in regards to taking
a picture.
But what I'm saying is,
I'm always
finding something new,
and this market changes so fast
that I'm just afraid
that you may have a good run
for three years,
five years and change with it,
or you may not.
The market's just moving
too fast for me, so I'm out.
Sorry to hear about that.
I don't really see
how this works
in the stadium
and event arena like that
because I think people
are engaged in the event more
than they're gonna go find
in a corner at your booth.
If you had said
you want to blow this up
for parties, weddings,
be premium,
the Cadillac or the Mercedes
of this, I would have been in.
But because of the direction
you want to take it,
‐I'm going out.
‐But I think it's both.
I'm sorry to hear that 'cause
it's actually both, but...
How do I get my dough back
if I'm just a 10% shareholder?
Well, I think I could actually
get your money back
just by expanding core business
and doubling that
in 12 to 18 months.
All of the concerns about
changing technology will occur.
There's also a wedding
next Sunday,
and somebody is gonna pay
for this thing.
I look at it as a company
that can support debt,
so here's an offer.
You don't have to take it,
but I'm not sure
you're gonna get anything else.
That's always a good sign,
right?
"You don't have to take it."
No, because I don't
want to take the risk of being
a minority shareholder
with no exit.
I'll loan you $350,000
at 18% interest.
I want 5% equity
in the company
as a fee for providing
that line.
‐It's the Loan Shark Tank again.
‐No, it isn't.
If you have a better structure,
Robert, you should provide it.
‐Are you done, Mr. O'Leary?
‐I'm not finished yet.
There's more?
I happen to think
you have to run like hell,
and I think
the more machines you get,
the more cash you'll make.
I'd be very careful
with your assumptions
about those other venues.
What I'd like to see
is you put them in a couple,
‐prove out your theory.
‐Sure.
Meanwhile, you're doing
weddings, my friend.
I love the business.
It's fantastic.
‐I'm with you on the venues.
‐Thank you.
I agree with Kevin
in that you got to run.
You got to go to every market.
Oh, we absolutely agree.
That's why we're standing here.
I mean, we've turned down money
to be right here, right now.
You got to go fast.
I really like
the corporate idea.
I think that's
gonna be really big.
But I need more equity.
How do I get more equity?
Well, what's your offer?
I need more than 10%.
How much do you need?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐I'd love to have 50%.
‐50%?
‐Yeah.
‐Whoa.
‐What?
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Sean and Ryan
are seeking $350,000
for 10% of their premium
photo booth company, Mirmir.
They have one offer from Kevin,
but Robert is also interested.
I'd love to have 50%.
‐50%?
‐Yeah.
‐Whoa.
‐What?
A full partnership.
Would you do a full partnership?
‐Why would you do that?
‐We wouldn't.
Well, I'm just asking.
Well, you're valuing
the business at $700,000.
No, I'm not asking
for that dollar amount.
What dollar amount
would you need?
At 50%?
I couldn't do a deal at 50%.
‐You couldn't?
‐No.
‐Oh, hell no.
‐At 50%?
'Cause we're churning out cash.
There is no way I'm gonna ‐‐ No.
John: I'm just asking
a question. Why not?
It was just a question.
I just wanted to know,
what would you sell 50% for?
I mean, we think ‐‐
We think it's more valuable
than that.
‐You asked for $350,000 for 10%.
‐Right.
Meaning the entire thing
is worth $3.5 million today.
Right.
He doesn't want to sell
a control position.
I think he's made it clear.
Okay.
I mean, I'm happy
to entertain more equity.
I think we're gonna explode.
I think we're gonna get big.
What's the most equity
you would sell today?
For the right dollar amount,
I would entertain
maybe 18% to 20%,
but that's on the high side.
Would you do 20% for $700,000?
Same valuation, just more equity
for the same price?
Yes.
20% for $700,000.
I think
I would do that, yes.
Because it would allow me
to expand even that much faster.
I'll give you $700,000
for 20%.
What do you think?
‐Yeah?
‐Yeah.
‐We'll take your deal.
‐You got a deal.
‐All right!
‐There you go.
‐Happy to do it.
‐Thanks, man.
‐I'm so excited!
‐We're gonna go kill it.
We're gonna kill it!
Thanks guys.
We appreciate your ‐‐
Hey, let's get a picture!
Let's get a picture!
‐Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: [ Laughs ]
Feels like he bought a toy.
I'm very excited.
Thank you.
It's very cute
'cause you like toys.
Love toys.
I love it.
And this is like
the ultimate toy.
Glenn: While we appreciate
Kevin's offer,
we came in for a partnership,
not just money,
which is why we're so happy
to be with Robert,
'cause, again,
he saw what we were doing,
he gave us the dollars,
and we're gonna go kill it.
Narrator: Earlier this season,
Cyndi Lee made a deal
with Lori Greiner
for her multi‐use silicon
kitchen tool, Safe Grabs.
I make millionaires.
That's what I'd like to do
with you.
All right.
Let's make a deal.
Narrator:
Let's see what she's up to now.
♪♪
Lee: My success
has been so lightning speed,
it's just unbelievable.
I make $2.4 million
in gross sales!
Yeah!
[ Laughs ]
You just take this,
you put it over ‐‐
no more kablooey.
The day after "Shark Tank,"
Lori went on QVC
and she sold out.
She did about $300,000
within less than 10 minutes!
Let's hurry up
and get these things out!
I knew I would get some orders
after "Shark Tank," but my God!
It would not stop!
The fulfillment was just crazy.
It was my mom and I
just wrapping,
fulfilling every single order.
120,000 units of the Safe Grabs.
No sleep!
Thank you
for everything.
When I came on "Shark Tank,"
I was in debt.
I was living with my parents.
I even had to take a retail job
just to support myself.
I'm finally moving
out of my parents' home,
and they don't have to worry
about me, and I'm gonna be okay.
This entrepreneur's journey
is very difficult.
You better have tenacity,
perseverance
because it is a long road.
But once you get there,
it is amazing.
"Shark Tank"
really gives you hope,
and when you get hope,
you don't give up.
"Shark Tank" has allowed me
to live my life
and get out of debt
and be financially set,
and what more could you ask for?
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a simple solution
to a dreaded household task.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Derrek Burr
and I'm from North Attleboro,
Massachusetts.
I am the president and C. E. O. of
Kwik‐Hang Curtain Rod Brackets.
Now, I'm here today
seeking an $80,000 investment
in exchange for a 20% equity
stake in our company.
Sharks, as a police officer
and a former Marine,
I've faced many challenges
in my life,
but none mightier
than hanging a curtain rod.
Now, our unique curtain hardware
is gonna change the way
that you hang your curtains,
making old
curtain hardware obsolete.
Introducing
Kwik‐Hang Curtain Rod Brackets,
one of a kind,
patented curtain rod brackets
that you can use
to hang your curtains
in a matter of seconds,
leaving no visible damage.
Now, our proprietary brackets
set themselves apart
from anything else on the market
by eliminating the need
for nails, screws, drilling,
measuring, or marring up
the face of your woodwork.
Now, we've taken the trouble
and aggravation
out of hanging your curtains.
Allow me to demonstrate
just how simple it is
to install our curtain hardware.
Blink, Sharks,
and you might just miss it.
[ Chuckles ]
Give it a few taps
on this side.
And a few taps
on that side.
You just tap it and you're done.
It's that easy.
Wow.
Now all you have to do
is hang your curtains.
See, Sharks,
I wasn't lying when I said
they install in seconds.
Very cool.
No fuss, no muss,
and no plaster dust.
But I know what you're probably
thinking right now.
Will they hold?
What I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna hang
two 10‐pound bags of potatoes
from the curtain rod.
I often do that.
[ Laughs ]
Good for you.
Wow.
Sharks, Kwik‐Hang
curtain hardware
is the fastest, strongest,
and simplest way
for you to hang
your curtains.
So don't leave me
hanging out here all by myself.
The window of opportunity
is open
for you to invest
in our company.
Thank you for time.
And I'll now pass out
some samples.
Cool. Good job.
I loved the demo.
Very effective.
So be very careful because there
are very sharp pins on these,
but Lori's are the white.
‐The white? Thank you.
‐Thank you.
‐Careful, they're sharp.
‐"Shahp."
Mr. Wonderful,
of course, you get gold.
Thank you.
Daymond, silver.
Mark.
‐Thank you.
This is a very thin
hook here.
Correct.
What about curtain rods
that are 1 to 1.5 inch
in diameter or larger?
Do you have different
sizes of this?
We do have different sizes.
So, right now,
we can hold curtain rods
from half‐inch
all the way up to an inch.
Why don't you have
the capability of going bigger?
Basically,
my dad started this company,
and he gave the customers
what they wanted.
But this is a piece
of metal, right...
Yes.
that's, like,
stamped or formed.
Right.
So why couldn't you
just form it to be 1.5 inches?
I mean, it's very possible,
it's just the tooling
is expensive to do that,
so we're just working
with what we have right now.
‐So it's tooling.
‐Correct.
Now, your dad started
the company?
He did.
Is he still
part of the company?
Uh, unfortunately,
we just lost him
this past April, so...
Oh, I'm sorry.
My dad was in the jewelry
business his whole life,
and he worked for a gentleman
that had a similar idea.
So my dad started
a little company on the side
and started selling them,
and he started
having some success.
So my dad went back
to his boss and said,
"Well, what if I go out,
I apply for the patents,
I get the inventory going?"
So my dad's boss basically
laughed at him and said,
"You're never gonna
make any money.
Go ahead."
And that's the wrong thing
to say to my dad.
You never challenge my dad
'cause he's gonna
prove you wrong.
‐And so he started the business.
‐He did.
How long ago?
2013.
And he was so proud
of those patents.
And Derrek,
what are your sales?
It's been about three years.
$120,000.
All right, what are your sales
just this year,
and what were they
last year?
So, this year, year‐to‐date,
we're at $31,000.
Last year, $42,000.
And what do they sell for,
and what do they cost you
to make?
Singles landed are $3.15.
We sell them for $10.95.
Doubles are $4.
We sell them for $17.95.
How do you sell them,
Derrek?
Everything is online.
So from my website, eBay,
and we just signed a deal
with Houzz.
So, what do you do
full time,
'cause obviously $31,000
isn't gonna pay the bills.
Right.
So full‐time,
I'm a police officer.
And who's running
the company?
I am.
But, Derrek,
you're making money.
I mean,
your margins are good.
On the $31,000,
you probably made,
what, $18,000,
something like that?
So, off the $31,000,
we've made about $7,000
'cause I've been trying
to grow the brand.
The business
was in my dad's apartment.
I got us
into a warehouse space.
I started having
the packaging done, so...
The real issue
about getting this
in broad distribution
is getting the packaging right
to tell the story
of what this does...
Right.
...which is gonna be
one challenge.
And then getting a distributor
that sells curtain rods.
‐Right.
‐Sell them together...
But the trouble is,
you're a full‐time ‐‐
and thank you again
for your service ‐‐
police officer.
This is not a crazy deal.
It's not overvalued
or anything.
It's just ‐‐
Who's gonna do the work?
You're looking at him.
Me running this business
is the one last link to my dad.
This business
meant everything to my dad,
and this makes me
still feel close to him.
So I would retire
from the police department
to run this business.
Wow.
Then I got to ask you
a question.
Are you motivated to do this
because it's in his honor,
or do you really
want to grow this business?
Because those are two
different things.
I'm passionate
about the business
because it was started
by my father and my mother,
and this is the only thing
that she has left of my dad.
This is the only thing
I have left of my dad.
So this is basically
everything for us.
Would you have the same
motivation to go on
with sales
of $30,000, $40,000?
You can't live off that.
But, Kevin,
with all due respect,
this is only with me
doing this part‐time.
If I had a Shark behind me
with the marketing and exposure,
I have doubt in my mind
that this thing could blow up.
Derrek, it wouldn't take off
the way you would expect it to.
Because there's still
blocking and tackling
that has to take place.
‐Right.
‐Right?
And so while what you've
accomplished is phenomenal,
what your dad
has accomplished,
but at the same time,
you're not investable yet
because you're still
figuring all this out.
I don't think you're ready,
and honestly,
it's not my wheelhouse,
it's not really my strong suit,
these types of products.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I mean, look, people have been
doubting me my whole life.
People told me
that I would never make it
through Marine Corps boot camp,
told me I didn't have
what it took,
said I was too small.
I served four years honorably
as a United States Marine,
and I earned a Navy & Marine
Corps achievement medal.
People said I would
never become a cop,
said it was not possible.
I've been on the police force
now for almost five years.
I continue to chase
my dreams.
Good for you.
To honor your father
is beautiful thing,
and you've already done it.
‐You're you.
‐Right.
So I think here,
I would take pause and stop
and think about ‐‐
Is this the life that you
want to live day to day?
‐Because it's a huge commitment.
‐Right.
You have four patents.
To me,
it's a licensing play.
Right.
And getting somebody
to buy that
and then they actually
have the manpower
to put it everywhere, to me,
would be the greatest
legacy your father ever had.
Right.
And, for me,
I know what it would take ‐‐
I mean, it's huge.
It's a huge
amount of effort.
For those reasons,
I personally need to be out.
Thank you.
There's a theory out there
that "I need to quit my job
and I need to just go,
you know, all out,"
and what you do is then
you can't pay the bills
and then you can't put
any money into the business.
Mm‐hmm.
You need to run
this business,
but I don't think you need
to quit your job, either.
It wouldn't be
in your best interest
for me to help because you need
to slowly grow this,
‐so I'm out.
‐Thank you.
The right path here
is going to find
that licensing deal
that Lori suggested to you.
Right.
You want to make him proud,
go get a royalty check
of $50,000 a month,
because you have these patents.
Right.
That's the gift
he really left you.
You have four.
Right. Right.
It's one of those deals that
it's just a beautiful story,
but as a business,
extremely hard to invest in.
I'm sorry, Derrek,
I'm out.
Derrek, I love the dream,
and you have great purpose.
Great businesses are started
with great purpose.
You know, my dad was thrown
in jail 23 times,
and, uh,
when I was 21 years old,
I was, uh ‐‐
I didn't know
what I wanted to do.
I was a bit of a mess,
partying, hanging out.
People would say, "What do you
want to do with your life?"
I'd go,
"Eh, it doesn't matter."
My dad sits down with me
and he says,
"I went through hell
so that you
could have the opportunity
I never had."
That was it.
And for the rest of my life,
people always said,
"Oh, how do you work so hard?
You only sleep
three hours a day."
It must be hard.
And I always used to say,
"Anything I do in lifetime
will never be as hard
as what that man went through."
But you've got to have something
that you can apply that to
in order to build
a bigger business.
I wouldn't quit
the job today.
The price point
is just too small.
But maybe
you'll figure it out.
I can't be in today,
but I wish you all the best.
I'm out.
Thank you all for your time.
Derrek,
can I shake your hand?
‐Sure.
‐Thank you very much.
My pleasure.
Thank you very much.
‐Wish you all the best.
‐Thank you.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Congrats, Derrek.
‐Thank you, guys.
‐Thank you, Derrek.
That's a good guy,
right there.
Derrek:
Yeah, I'm disappointed.
I got a little
knocked down today,
but my dad never gave up
on this product,
and neither will I.
I'm going to definitely
prove them wrong.
It's hard to look at that
and not want to help him,
but you realize
it's not a business.
It's small.
It's not
that he's not a business.
He's just not ready.
It's just small.
It's hard.
Right?
He'll figure it out.
He's got time.
He's just here too early.
I love the passion, though.
I love the drive.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product that is fun
and functional.
♪♪
Schultz: Hello, Sharks.
My name is Doug Schultz
and this is Justin Rietema,
and we are the inventors
of the Human Bobber
line of flotation products.
We're here today
seeking $120,000
for 15% stake
in our company.
Sharks, Doug and I love
being out in the water,
and living in Florida,
we have lots of opportunities
to do just that.
Whether it's a river, lake,
or ocean,
we want to be outdoors
with our friends ‐‐
boating, wakeboarding,
or floating ‐‐
in any opportunity
possible.
'Case we all know
what the best part
about boating is,
right, Sharks?
You know what it is!
It's cracking open
a cold one
and floating behind the boat
with your buddies.
Yes.
But things like rafts,
noodles, inflatables ‐‐
they're impossible
to stay on.
You fall in the water
and you get water in your beer.
Not cool!
Inflatables ‐‐ hard to blow up,
take up so much room.
Eventually, we said
to heck with all that stuff,
left the floats
and clutter at home.
We just used an old life vests
to float around.
So one afternoon,
while floating around
in our life vests,
uncomfortably, of course...
Oh, yeah.
...and probably after
a few too many cold ones...
Probably.
[ Laughs ]
...Doug and I decided
to change the game
and create one all‐inclusive
personal flotation device.
And that day, the Bottoms Up
dual‐purpose vest was born.
This is the world's first
Coast Guard‐approved,
multifunctional
personal floatation device.
This replaces your required
Coast Guard‐approved
boating vest,
your specialty watersports vest,
and all your rafts,
noodles, and inflatables
with one easy‐to‐use,
comfortable,
easy‐to‐store device.
But wait, Sharks!
That's not it!
We also have our
Scuttlebutt triple‐purpose line
of recreational
floatation devices.
‐Hey!
‐Okay!
‐Hot models everywhere.
You guys were quiet!
With the Scuttlebutt,
you can float in it,
you can float on it,
or you can sit on it
for all your floatation
and recreational needs.
Also, our Bottoms Up,
you can use it
for all your watersports needs.
And then when you're done,
you simply flip it upside down,
jump in the water for a full day
of relaxation and floatation.
And when you add in
all the extra Scuttlebutt
configurations,
you and your friends
you're in for a good day
on the water,
and you won't be getting water
in your drink
wearing these bad boys.
Sharks, our products
are the all‐in‐one, get‐it‐done,
have‐fun‐in‐the‐sun,
slam‐dunk, home‐run,
best floatation
devices on the market.
So, Sharks...
Together: Who wants to join
our float club?
O'Leary:
I've got a lake house.
I've got a few
of the chair things.
They're made out of foam.
They're very inexpensive.
How much does that one cost?
So, we sell these for $65,
and the vest, we sell for $90.
How much does it cost you
to make each one?
The Bottoms Up
dual‐purpose vest
we get for $27.80,
including shipping.
The Scuttlebutt triple‐purpose,
we get for $22.80.
So, let's understand
your business.
How many have you sold?
So, to date,
we sold $63,000
and we've been selling
for three years.
‐Oh!
‐Whoa.
That may not sound great.
You're right,
it doesn't.
I know, but we started
the production of this
and the idea six years ago,
and it took us two to three
years just in the development,
working back and forth
with the manufacturer.
Right.
And the patent process
and the Coast Guard process
alone has been
a three‐year ordeal.
Why only $63,000 in sales
over three years?
About three years ago,
we're like, "Oh, my God!
We're gonna go
for every big‐box retailer."
And we went to them,
and they were like, "We love it!
Is it Coast Guard approved?"
No.
"All right, guys, well, come
back and see us when it is."
The challenge is gonna be
demonstrating it,
because people
are gonna look at it,
and maybe
you have a hang tag,
but you're gonna have to have
a point‐of‐purchase display.
There's just so much
expense involved.
Well, that sounds
like a nightmare.
‐I don't like that.
‐No, that's right.
My two cents is you're gonna
have to do that online,
you know, when people
are looking to make
those purchase decisions.
‐Too small a market.
‐Yeah, it's too small.
Well, maybe the market's
not as huge, but look,
one of the worst things
that could happen
is you get a big order
from a big box
and it doesn't sell
and you're out of business.
You know, the funny thing
about your deal,
I got to be honest with you,
is I spend all of my time
in the lake
in one of those foam chairs
with a bottle of Chardonnay.
[ Laughs ]
And I sit around
and direct traffic
when my kids are going
in and out of the boats.
I'm like the traffic cop
in the chair.
I am definitely gonna buy
one of these, but I'm trying ‐‐
Would you float around in it
or your chair?
Well, the trouble
with the chair, actually, is ‐‐
This is better,
because the chair,
you have to actually
balance yourself,
and the more you drink,
the worse it gets.
So I just ‐‐
The thing about "Shark Tank"
is you get nailed
on the real problem.
This thing is ‐‐
It's a great product.
It's gonna be hanging
in the marina.
Who's gonna know
what it is?
I think by literally
hanging it upside‐down...
I mean,
as they're flipping through,
most of them are on a rack.
I would say the idiot kid
at the store
hung the thing upside down
by mistake.
It's actually detailed by ‐‐
One things entrepreneurs
always have to learn
is when it's your product,
you just think
everybody's focused on it
and you perceive
"This is how I would do it
if I were the customer."
It's never that way.
You always have to perceive
that your customer
doesn't care
about your product.
You have to make them care.
And to that avail, I would say
that's why we're here.
We're creative guys.
We've pushed this thing
for six years,
and we're ready
for a strategic investor.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $120,000
for 33.3%.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
Doug and Justin have an offer
on the table from Kevin O'Leary
for the multi‐functional
life vest, Human Bobber.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll give you $120,000
for 33.3%.
That's actually
a really good offer.
Will we be entertaining
anyone else's offers?
I don't think
I'm gonna have a lot
of competition on this one,
I got to be honest with you.
[ Laughs ]
I'm basically paying $120,000
for a life jacket
I can float and drink in.
That's about it.
Cuban: See, here's where
my head's at.
One, I've got a great deal
with Amazon Exclusives.
Right? I have my own
Amazon Exclusive page.
We can get you
your own.
Two, Tower Paddle Board
is an online marketing machine.
But then,
on the flip side,
the untold secret
of "Shark Tank" Season 8 now
is that having done this
and having
71 "Shark Tank" deals,
I already know that your
accounting's gonna be a mess,
that I'm gonna have to come in
and clean you all up,
and I'm so sick and tired
of babysitting companies
at that level.
You guys don't even have
an income statement, right?
I mean,
it's a spreadsheet.
Let's not get
ahead of ourselves.
QuickBooks
was way too expensive.
Well, you know,
I think it's very clever.
You did a better mousetrap
on something
that's been kind of boring.
But sometimes,
investing in business,
to me, feels almost like
a poker game, you know?
You don't know what's the next
card that's gonna come.
And, to me, you're either
all in or you fold.
And I'm looking at this
and I'm thinking
I'm gonna have to fold.
You're just starting,
so I'm out.
‐Thank you very much.
‐Thank you.
It's gonna be very difficult
to build a company around this.
This is a feature
to an existing product.
Everybody buys
one life jacket.
People are not gonna buy
another life jacket
even if you can float
into it.
The path to riches in this
is to license it
so that it is the only
life jacket that people buy.
It's not a company today.
I'm out.
We look at,
where's the opportunity,
but then where
is the distribution
and the pipeline that you
can tap into that we have?
Even if I go to my guys
over at Bass Pro,
I can't support them.
I can't push people
into retail,
and if you can't
help support retail,
then you end up failing.
So, in this instance,
I wouldn't be able to help
distribute it, so I'm out.
Well, you have an offer
on the table ‐‐ Kevin's.
Yes, we do,
and it's a great offer.
And Mark hasn't
made up his mind.
Are you looking
at this?
Okay, I'll consider helping
Kevin, but let me ‐‐
I'll let you guys
convince Kevin of this.
Why would anybody
help Kevin?
Because I want
to help them.
You asked for 33.3%?
I got to have
at least that, yeah.
That's fine.
10% of that goes to me,
and I'll hook them up
with the Amazon Exclusives
and connect them
with Tower Paddle Board
and let them use
my back office
'cause I know
their accounting sucks, right?
Yeah, look,
that makes sense.
Guys, this is such
a great deal.
But, Kevin,
I'm not putting in any cash.
[ Laughs ]
So you want me
to fund your 10%?
Yes, because ‐‐
I don't have to make
that decision now.
Mark, when did you lose
all your money?
You need Kevin to fund you?
Look, I'm not gonna do that.
I got to wet my beak.
[ Laughs ]
Mark, In eight years, I never
thought I would see this happen.
Kevin has to pay your way.
That's not gonna happen.
But, look,
at the end of the day ‐‐
It's worth it,
so you have to convince him.
So, Kevin, how much
of the company
are you willing
to offer Mark for ‐‐
None.
Everybody pays in my world.
Everybody gets paid
in mine.
Justin and Doug,
here's the deal.
Put $120,000 up
for 33.3%.
But Cuban's a partner
on this with me,
and he's getting paid equity.
So he gets 10%.
And you understand
the 10% that Mark is getting
is coming from you,
so I'm funding the company
‐for 33.3%.
‐43.3% total.
And 10% is your...
That's my number.
What are you gonna do?
Well, we appreciate
the offers,
and as crazy
as it may sound,
we're gonna take the offer
'cause we want to see
this thing go somewhere.
‐Smart man!
We've been at it
for six years, man.
Smart man.
We want to see it
turn into something.
‐Appreciate it.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Wow.
‐Appreciate it, Mark.
Congrats.
You got to leave
one of these here for me.
‐Mark, thanks a lot.
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Appreciate it.
‐Thanks for all that time.
‐Bye, guys.
‐All right.
Congrats.
Yeah, dude!
[ Laughs ]
That's how we bob!
So, I'm pretty sure
we just gave up
10% of our company
for free,
and that may be
a "Shark Tank" first.
And it sounded pretty crazy
when we first heard it,
but I think it's gonna pay off
in the long run.
Having two Sharks
on our team,
we're gonna be able to take
this company sky high.